salut aujourd'hui je vais vous emmener
en expédition au coeur de la citadelle
de kun a lieu mythique qui a marqué
littéralement la ville de hong kong un
lieu sans aucun gouvernement avec ses
propres règles et surtout un lieu avec
50000 habitants livrés à eux mêmes
comment pourrait-on expliquer
l'existence d'un tel dieu qu'est ce qui
se passe vraiment là bas à l'intérieur
pour entrer dans cette citadelle je ne
serai pas seul je serai accompagné par
charlie dangers de la chaîne les revues
du monde qui marraine ce septième
épisode bonjour je suis super heureuse
d'être côte est de fait dans pour vous
raconter
de colonne qu'on appelle également la
cité des ténèbres on va vous raconter
cette histoire cos
bienvenue d'un cabinet curieuse
[Musique]
avant de vous expliquer les détails
croustillants de la citadelle regardez
cette image c'est précisément de ça dont
nous parlons un amas de bâtiments les
uns sur les autres au coeur de l'île de
hong kong on arrive même à distinguer
des rues un petit peu entre les
bâtiments ici s'applique des règles
spéciales les règles de la citadelle
même le climat est différent de celui de
hong kong il s'agit de l'endroit le plus
densément peuplés au monde et ce qui s'y
passe à l'intérieur est hallucinant
avant de vous en parler revenons-en au
pourquoi pourquoi cette mini ville dans
la ville de hong kong at elle vu le jour
pourquoi est ce si densément peuplées
comment en est on arrivé là c'est
charlie et à la réponse à ces questions
avant d'être cet ensemble d'immeubles il
y avait juste un petit fort qui avait
été construit pour abriter les soldats
chinois qui contrôlait le commerce du
sel cet endroit n'était donc pas du tout
destiné à devenir une petite ville nous
sommes en 1839 une guerre éclate lempire
ching en chine et le royaume uni lorsque
chinois interdisent l'importation et
lusage de l'opium et on aimait bien
l'opium en europe ça devienne une guerre
parce que le royaume uni a le monopole
de la vente de drogue en chine c'est un
business très lucratif pour les
britanniques du coup l'interdiction
prononcée par les chinois pose un petit
problème au royaume uni et c'est le
début d'un petit conflit commercial
nommé la guerre de l'opium vous aurez
peut-être du mal à le croire mais les
britanniques remportent la guerre en
1842 et ils peuvent désormais vendre de
l'opium en chine et grâce à leur
victoire la ville de hong kong devrait
céder et devient donc une colonie
britannique sauf la cité de clowns qui
appartient toujours à la chine les
autorités chinoises décident de
construire une forteresse autour de la
fameuse cité de clown pour
contrebalancer l'influencé des
britanniques sur le secteur ils veulent
préserver leur territoire et c'est aussi
à partir de là qu'on l'appellera la cité
en murray mais coup de théâtre les
britanniques attaque la citadelle et la
zone se retrouve un peu à l'abandon ni
la chine
le royaume uni devront tenir compte de
cette zone pour eux cet endroit est à
oublier qu loonois old city n'applique
donc aucune règle du gouvernement et
dispose de ses propres règles et entre
nous une zone sans foi ni loi ça donne
rarement quelque chose de super chouette
le temps passe nous sommes maintenant en
1949 et mao arrive au pouvoir à ce
moment là beaucoup de chinois cherchent
à fuir le régime politique et se réfugie
dans la cité colonne et c'est là que les
choses évoluent la ville atteint 5000
personnes en 1950 puis dix mille et des
dizaines de commerces en 1973 et
continue à grimper comme ça jusqu'à
50000 habitants en 1990 c'est
impressionnant une densité d'habitants
équivalente à quasiment 2 millions de
personnes par kilomètre carré on
pourrait se demander quelle est la vie
de ses habitants à l'intérieur de ses
murs cette question le photographe greg
girard se les poser il s'est faufilé
dans les ruelles sombres de la cité des
ténèbres pour enquêter et prendre
quelques clichés à couper le souffle
vous verrez plusieurs de ses photos au
fil de la vie des petites parenthèses il
est également auteur du livre city of
darkness revisited écrit avec yann
lambotte un autre photographe je vous
mets le lien description si ça vous
intéresse avec l'afflux de réfugiés
chinois coup le new old city entre dans
une pénurie de logements et si la cité
ne peut pas s'étendre à l'horizontale
elle le fera à la verticale des
immeubles de grande hauteur se
construisent jusqu'à 14 étages
pourquoi est ce que les habitants ils
n'ont pas réussit à étaler un petit peu
plus de reconstruction pour être moins
les uns sur les autres pour rappel le
territoire autour de la cité il
appartient au britannique et n'ont pas
le droit de construire autour d'où le
fait d'avoir fait de très très aux
immeubles comme ça à votre avis combien
d'immeubles ont été construits dans
cette petite zone 10 5 ans 200 et ben
c'est vous et manque plus que ça ce sont
près de 300 immeubles 3 centimes c'est
colossal sur une zone aussi petit que
trois stades de foot
moins de deux fois la taille du stade de
france et ce qui est étonnant c'est une
sorte de hiérarchie se met en place dans
cette enclave où les plus pauvres vivent
bas et où les plus riches ont la chance
de vivre en eau captant ainsi la lumière
naturelle forcément quasi inexistante
ailleurs dans la cité les toits reste
tout de même des endroits communautaire
où la population se retrouvent pour
partager des moments conviviaux comme
faire jouer des enfants ou encore faire
la lessive
évidemment ça n'est pas paradisiaque
mais au moins on voit le ciel on voit
aussi que tout n'est pas vraiment noir
dans cette cité des ténèbres et c'est ce
qu'a également constaté girard qui
explique que la ville a une culture de
village et qu'une certaine solidarité y
est présent mais redescendons d'un étage
en bas la zone est tellement dense les
russes sont si étroites et les immeubles
see you que la lumière n'entre pas les
rues pour la plupart ne font même pas
deux mètres de large imaginez-vous juste
un petit peu être plongé dans une nuit
continue d'ailleurs selon le photographe
gérard c'est comme si la ville disposait
de son propre micro climat puisque en
raison des tuyaux défilé des gouttières
ouverte l'atmosphère y est très chaud et
très humide pour la petite anecdote
pendant son expédition girard rencontre
le facteur de la deal qui porte un
chapeau pour se protéger tant il y à des
gouttes qui tombent du plafond sur son
visage niveau confort c'est pas le top
mais il ya quand même de l'électricité
et de l'eau dans la cité enfin presque
tout le temps pas tout le temps parce
que la cité à détourner l'eau et
l'électricité de hong kong donc c'est
assez compliqué au quotidien par la
suite les autorités instable tout de
même quelques fontaines à eau mais
seulement 8 pour des milliers
d'habitants et leur usine économiquement
parlant la cité de clown est considérée
comme une économie parallèle à hong kong
puisque des commerces et des restaurants
pousse à chaque coin de rue une aubaine
pour beaucoup d'entrepreneurs puisque
les loyers sont moins élevés mais pas
que puisque c'est une zone de non droit
c'est aussi une zone de non droit
pas besoin de les respecter le code du
travail par exemple ce qui permet à
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs d'y faire
produire des biens à moindre coût c'est
tout aussi avantageux pour les médecins
les dentistes qui peuvent exercer sans
disposer de diplôme ou d'une quelconque
licence et je ne vous parle même pas du
risque d'infection colonne c'est aussi
la cité du crime de la prostitution et
du trafic de drogue bah oui c'est
l'endroit parfait pour les criminels qui
veulent se cacher et éviter les
poursuites et d'ailleurs si la deal
n'est pas gouvernée elle est tout de
même contrôlé par les triades des
sociétés secrètes chinoise en bref on
comprend bien que si autant de personnes
ont décidé de poser leurs bagages
s'était emmuré est lancé pour l'absence
de réglementation et pour éviter la
faillite
l'expulsion et la pauvreté même si
paradoxalement les conditions de vie ils
sont assez terrible pour l'anecdote il y
a des carcasses d'animaux dans les rues
donc je vous laisse imaginer le niveau
de propreté les odeurs nauséabondes et
le risque évident de maladies mère du
coup comment est-ce que ça se termine
cette histoire fabien pas si mal même si
cette fin est loin d'être parfaite nous
sommes alors en 1984 des négociations se
font entre les chinois les britanniques
et ces derniers souhaitent finalement
redonné hong kong à la chine et en
profiter pour détruire coulonnois old
city une cité qui au final pose un
problème à hong kong parce que à ce
moment précis la ville commence à se
moderniser neuf ans plus tard en 1993 la
cité est complètement rasé et qu'est ce
qu'il s'est passé pour tous ses
habitants eh ben il a fallu tous les
reloger le gouvernement a dépensé
jusqu'à 3 milliards de dollars pour
remplacer ses habitants et ses commerces
les habitants ont toutefois reçu une
compensation de ses concerts mais qui
selon eux n'est pas assez conséquente
aujourd'hui la cité a laissé place à un
magnifique parc qui met en lumière
cet héritage historique
[Musique]
merci charlie d'avoir participé à cet
épisode si vous êtes curieux
d'archéologie d'histoire d'anthropologie
découverte je vous recommande vivement
de faire un tour sur sa chaîne
passionnante les revues du monde que
vous trouverez évidemment en lien dans
la description merci beaucoup à toi pas
besoin d'eux pour cette invitation
c'était très cool a très vite et c'était
pas à passer sur un charme si vous me
connaissez pas je m'appelle toujours
voilà c'est ça fabien olicard le
prochain épisode de cabinet curieuse
bête publiés le mois prochain et parlera
du mystérieux triangle des bermudes
quant à la prochaine vidéo elle arrive
dans quelques jours sur cette chaîne
youtube et si jamais vous voulez voir
d'ici là tous les numéros de cabinet
curieuse vous avez tous les épisodes et
les liens correspondants dans la
description vous pouvez aussi encore
faire du bien à votre curiosité en
lisant mon magazine q auriez vous un
magazine mensuel de 60 pages qui est
livrée directement dans votre boîte aux
lettres partout dans le monde le lien
est aussi évidemment dans la description
ici je vous mets deux anciens épisodes
déjà parus prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt ciao
[Musique]
tous